[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're diving deep in the law and
unearthing 10 lesser-known Harry Potter
theories that you likely haven't heard
of before these are the sorts of
theories that'll make you think ah I
never thought of that it might even hold
the power to change the way you see the
Wizarding World anyway let's get to it
the secret behind magical portraits in
The Wizarding World magical portrait
serves a way of immortalizing deceased
witches and wizards long after they have
passed away this ensures that their
knowledge and wisdom can be passed down
to Future generations and while many
Wizarding portraits are simply still
images much like Muckle portraits a
great number of them are enchanted and
brought to life via Enchanted paint
allowing the portrait to emulate the
behavior and mannerisms of the portrait
subject however like anything there are
levels to how advanced these portraits
can be with Headmasters portraits being
the most technical
conventional wisdom suggests that had
Masters portraits are painted well
before their deaths kept away in hidden
locations where only their living
counterparts are able to interact with
them following the portrait's initial
creation the subjects would then visit
their paintings as often as possible
imparting memories and wisdom onto them
basically teaching the paintings how to
be them through this process they are
able to become very good representations
of these witches and wizards but I don't
know if I'm entirely convinced some of
these portraits like Dumbledore's and
snapes seem far too alive and capable
which leads me to question the process
Rowling has stated that the type of
portrait typically corresponds to the
power and abilities of the witch or
wizard who is featured in the painting
this suggests that the more powerful of
which your wizard was in life the more
life like their portrait stands to be at
least as far as headmaster's portraits
are concerned I think it's entirely
possible that a tiny sliver of the
subject's soul is willingly in planted
into the portrait allowing the portrait
to exhibit such lifelike Behavior if
you're already on your deathbed why not
preserve a little piece of yourself to
bestow wisdom upon the generations to
come it's entirely possible that
splitting the soul even in such an
infinitesimal way would entirely
contradict what some of these main
characters stand for but it's a fun
thought
Hogwarts is sentient Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and was a dream is a magical
place of all of Enchantment and mystery
that was created by its four founding
members godric Gryffindor Salazar
Slytherin Helga Hufflepuff and Rowena
Ravenclaw while each of the founding
members was responsible for bringing
something to the table during the
creation of the school the founder most
responsible for its architecture was
probably Rowena Ravenclaw as she was
influential in the creation of the
castle as well as the school's
ever-changing floor plan Hogwarts is
undoubtedly spectacular to look at an
unquestionable architectural Marvel but
it does seem like there's an underlying
element of mystery to the castle
wouldn't you agree the theory I've got
for you suggests that the castle itself
is actually a sentient being capable of
understanding and reacting to the
emotions and events happening within its
walls this would explain the
ever-changing staircases the hidden
passages and a seemingly endless array
of secret rooms the founders were able
to turn a regular hat into a sentient
being the Sorting Hat in order to
perpetuate their belief systems so I
can't imagine why they wouldn't have
extended this sort of magic to the very
walls of the castle a step further what
if the Hogwarts Founders inserted their
own Consciousness into the school's
walls thestrals are science experiments
thestrals are a mysterious breed of
winged horse with skeletal and reptilian
features resembling a sort of evil
Pegasus the following excerpt from the
Order of the Phoenix depicts Harry's
initial reaction to thestrals if he had
to give them a name he supposed he would
have called them horses though there was
something reptilian about them too they
were completely flashless their black
coats clinging to their skeletons of
which every bone was visible their heads
were dragonish and their pupilous eyes
white and staring Wings sprouted from
each wither vast black leathery wings
that looked as though they ought to
belong to giant bats standing still in
quiet in the Gathering Gloom the
creatures looked eerie and sinister
the ministry of magic considers thestral
to be dangerous as they have a bad rap
as Omens of Misfortune because they are
only visible to those who have seen
death the theory I've got for you today
suggests that thestrals are not
naturally occurring creatures sprouted
from nature but are in fact the result
of dark arts experiments by evil wizards
in The Wizarding World there is such a
thing as a regularing tools and so the
theory posits that destroys were once
ordinary winged horses that became
exposed to dark magic though not even
remotely as evil perhaps thestrals are
to winged horses as Dementors are to
witches and wizards Neville longbottoms
clumsiness Neville is well known for his
clumsiness and forgetfulness and this
aspect of Neville's character is
reinforced again and again for a large
portion of the series some of it can be
explained by his wand you see for most
of his life Neville's wand isn't
Neville's at all it actually originally
belonged to his father Frank Longbottom
we know that the one chooses the wizard
so having a wand handed down to you is a
Surefire way of stunting your magical
abilities but that doesn't explain
everything Neville was clumsy Beyond
just performing spells the theory I'm
about to introduce suggests that
Neville's grandmother Augusta is to
blame after Neville's parents were
tortured to Insanity he was sent to live
with his grandmother Augusta Augusta was
the mother of Neville's father Frank
Longbottom and longed for Neville to
grow up to be just like his father
however Neville's early ineptitude led
to her being quite disappointed in her
grandson the theory that I want to
introduce today suggests that during
Neville's youth Augusta may have cast a
confundus charm on the young boy there
are a few angles the first is that
Augusta did this entirely by accident
though she was a talented witch in her
own rights Augusta was no spring chicken
so it's possible that she simply casts
the spell or Neville by accident while
trying to achieve some sort of other
result the next is that Auguste
intentionally casts the speller Neville
in order to protect him from potential
Death Eater attacks the rationale here
being that if Neville appeared less
capable then he would be less of a
Target Augusta had gone through the
traumatizing process of witnessing her
capable Brave and impressive son
tortured to Insanity leaving behind an
empty shell it's entirely possible that
Augusta Clinging On To The hope that
Neville would turn out like Frank
sheltered the boy in order to protect
him if true this would explain Neville's
sudden urge of competence and bravery in
the later books as the charms effects
may have started to wear off the mirror
of arised reveals even more than meets
the eye the maravara said is a magical
mirror and shows us the deepest most
desperate desires of our hearts this is
reflected in the mirror's name no pun
intended as error said flipped around
reads as desire the mirror itself was
made some time before the end of the
19th century and is located in the room
of requirement in Hogwarts engraved on
the mirror the words erasad straw aruite
Ube cafru oyt on hwasi which backwards
reads as I show not your face but your
heart's desire and while conventional
wisdom suggests that what's shown in the
mirror is a very much intangible
reflection of one's desires the theory
I've got for you today really takes it a
step further this Theory suggests that
the mirror is actually a portal to an
alternate reality where the viewer's
desires have come true this would
explain the mirror's ability to show
such vivid and realistic images as well
as its potential to become addictive and
dangerous to those who gaze into it for
too long we've seen other enigmatic
gateways in the Harry Potter Universe
such as the veil so the idea that this
magical artifact crosses
interdimensional boundaries is not
entirely out of the question if true
this would add a new dimension to the
miravera said and its role in the series
transforming it from a mere reflection
of desire to a gateway to another world
the Philosopher's Stone is a horcrux
Nicola Flamel was a French scribe born
in the year 1330 that is said to be
responsible for the creation of the
fabled alchemical creation the
Philosopher's Stone is a real-life
historical figure that was adapted by JK
Rowling over the course of his life
Flamel had two great big understatement
there achievements in the realm of
alchemy the first was his creation of
the Philosopher's Stone an object with
the ability to turn base Metals into
gold the second and the one we're going
to discuss in depth was his creation of
the elixir of Life a potion made from
the Philosopher's Stone that granted the
Drinker immortality because of flamel's
elixir of life he ended up one of the
longest living Wizards in history
however fearing that the stone would one
day fall into the wrong hands Flamel and
Dumbledore devised a plan to destroy it
the Stone's destruction however came at
a great price flamel's life the theory
I've got for you today deposits that
flamel's Philosopher's Stone was an
object not unlike Voldemort's horcruxes
and anchored the Mortal realm just like
Voldemort stowed pieces of his soul into
physical objects Flamel Stone contained
fragments of his soul that tethered him
to life did the Philosopher's Stone
really keep Flamel alive because of his
supposed elixir of life or was filmal
just a fraud that relied on the Stone's
existence to remain in the land of the
living this theory of course paints
Flamel in a bit of a morally dubious
light but it's interesting to think
about Harry's class size did you ever
think that for the greatest Wizarding
School in the world Harry's class sizes
seemed a little small
for the number of wizards across the
globe it seems unlikely that one of the
pillars of Wizarding education would
boast such a small number of aspiring
young witches and wizards well I may
have an explanation this Theory suggests
that because so many witches and wizards
were killed during the first Wizarding
War the significant hit to the wizard
population resulted in far fewer
students harizier along with the
surrounding years would have been the
children and grandchildren of those who
perished or were otherwise affected by
the war the decrease in population would
naturally result in fewer students being
born during that time leading to smaller
class sizes at Hogwarts it's a grim
thought but it makes sense when you
consider the devastating impact that
Voldemort and the Death Eaters had on
the Wizarding World the Deathly Hallows
and Rule of Three Harry Potter is known
for its rule of sevens in The Wizarding
World the number seven is considered to
be the most powerful magical number as
such there are many sevens on display
for us in the Harry Potter story seven
times that Voldemort split his soul
seven Weasley children and seven
galleons for Harry's first wand but I
think that another overlooked number in
the series is three this Theory
discusses the notion that the three
Deathly Hallows the Elder Wand the
resurrection Stone and the invisibility
cloak represent the trio of Harry
Hermione and Ron respectively Harry is
the true Master of the Elder Wand
Hermione is the brains who could
metaphorically bring back the Dead with
her knowledge and Ron is often
overshadowed by his friends much like
someone wearing the invisibility cloak
at least this is true for the film
version of his character this Theory
connects the Beloved Trio and the
legendary Hallows the Goblet of Fire's
Secret The Goblet of Fire is the magical
artifact used to select champions for
the Triwizard Tournament the Goblet was
first used in 1294 when it was
introduced for the very first tournament
on record what's interesting about the
Goblet however is that its creation is
shrouded in mystery leaving many to
wonder about its true nature and Origins
the theory I've got for you today
suggests that the Goblet of Fire much
like the Sorting Hat is in fact a
sentient magical artifact incapable of
making decisions and judgments based on
the intentions and desires of those who
submit their names this would explain
the goblet's ability to assess the
worthiness of each applicant and select
the most worthy Champions as it would
possess a deep understanding of each
individual's character and potential
this may also explain its susceptibility
to magical tampering as this would allow
it to be influenced by the intentions of
anyone who cast a spell on the Goblet if
the Goblet of Fire is indeed sentient
the only question that remains is who
created it fire water air and Earth this
Theory posits that the four houses of
Hogwarts are linked with the four
classical elements Gryffindor the Brave
and daring represents fire this
passionate and fierce element is known
for its power and intensity much like
the courageous students of Griffin
fire symbolizes the burning desire to
stand up for what is right and the
unwavering determination to face
challenges head on characteristics that
are deeply ingrained in the spirit of
Gryffindor House Ravenclaw the wise and
intellectual symbolizes air this element
is associated with the Mind knowledge
and communication perfectly reflecting
the values of Ravenclaw students air
represents the boundless curiosity and
thirst for knowledge that drives the
pursuit of wisdom and understanding
qualities that are highly respected and
nurtured within the Ravenclaw house
Hufflepuff the loyal and hard-working
embodies Earth as the most grounded and
stable of the four elements Earth
symbolizes the unwavering loyalty
steadfastness and dedication that our
Hallmarks of Hufflepuff house Earth
represents the nurturing and supportive
nature of hufflepuffs who are known for
their strong sense of community and
commitment to fairness and equality and
finally Slytherin the cunning and
ambitious signifies water this element
is often associated with depth
adaptability and the ability to navigate
the complexities of Life water
represents the resourcefulness and
ambition that drives other in students
to achieve their goals often with a
level of subtlety and cunning that is
unmatched the fluidity and adaptability
of water reflect the Slytherin House's
ability to navigate through challenges
always seeking the most advantageous
path and that's it for this video what
do you think of these theories which did
you like which didn't you like please
leave a comment down below with your
thoughts and be sure to include any
Harry Potter theories of your own until
next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to live